era um total de dez anos mais golos mas
convicta direção do telex e é o meu
objetivo
nesta mensagem foi falar sobre
racionaliza sair já que é um tema
bastante atual
nós queremos pessoas não têm noção do
que é mais uma questão de
conscientização que temos bem a noção de
que temos entre outras de nosso
comportamento só para uma numa primeira
abordagem é eu gostava se ele plantar a
platéia enquanto só 62 foram consultar o
assembléia enquanto o acesso em coisas
foram consultar as vossas contas
bancárias
enquanto isso é que foram ver o consumo
da nossa casa
tanto é que nós podemos estar a falar em
eficiência energética
se nós não temos a mínima noção do que é
construir só para terem uma noção e eu
consumi jeito com mundial e sobre as
provas portugal
nós consumimos em média mil e dois mil e
quinhentos quilos por pessoa para terem
mais ou menos avançavam 1 quilo mudaria
para iluminar toda a vossa casa e termos
nada das cenas o editor estupro conforme
o crescimento da população vai para o
crescimento eo jeito senão tomaremos
mais que tudo não é internacional
temos que inverter no caso esta situação
focado aqui um carro nos nossos
edifícios nas nossas casas na nossa
preocupação é para ter praticamente 40%
do consumo energético é nível europeu é
vídeo aos edifícios olhada aí é que mais
penaliza da mente
apesar de falarmos muito engessado
levadas ainda a nossa cruz a energia
elétrica é essa desfeita por
combustíveis fósseis gráfico 65 do
consumo elétrico
dias fósseis desfilar aqui pra área
residencial e comercial também que 96
por cento do nosso consumo em casa pra
aquecer nos protegermos alunas ela para
as brigadas 96% vai ter falsas aos 11
conseguimos construir isto este grava
quero explicar em cada uma está o que é
que eu falei é um q1 de troll daria para
iluminar uma casa durante um ano inteiro
nos dia 10 e combustível pés no sistema
da reta transformação - dia 7 que somos
sábios sete quilos do troll para
conseguirmos eliminar a nossa casa neste
momento já todos ouvimos falar em
eficiência energética nas estratégias de
equipamentos mais eficientes em dias
renováveis já inclusivamente ouvimos
muito falar agora na sustentabilidade é
difícil mas tudo o que não serve pra mim
um sistemas de energias renováveis e
sistemas sustentáveis quando da minha
casa é um moto ingênuo não têm
estratégias que o consumo foi foi num
projecto europeu tentou vários anos
atrás tentou sentar passar a mensagem
que se melhorarmos a eficiência
energética nos ocupávamos primeiro ela
não funcionou realmente tentamos
associar então a ao consumo que não
estamos a contribuir pra
são do planeta ela também não funcionam
crianças socialmente estaremos a
contribuir para mostrar muito mais
sustentável
mas a mensagem chame mais funcionou foi
nós estamos a fazer melhor do que nosso
vizinho
e como num projecto mais a 10 europeu
foram instalados monitores de
analisadores rede de energia e utilizar
os cerca de 230 edifícios em especial
pelos em portugal inclusivamente
contribuiu com 35% dessa mostra desde 35
por cento de edifícios foram
monitorizados 7 milhão e tal
equipamentos de climatização nessa e os
equipamentos desde o século 18 ao
equipamento conseguiu se ver só o fato
de terem monitorização conseguia na
ordem dos 5
chegamos inclusive edifícios pelo
sistema de monitorização
não tenho a obsessão do que tenham os
equipamentos ligados 24 horas 24 275 8
mil 760 horas por ano
bombas chamas caldeiras tudo isso sempre
ligar porque não tem um sistema de uma
transação hostil também não sabe uma
coisa difícil então chegaram a
ultrapassar por peças na ordem dos 30
por cento em média
o projeto global nessa sua sede é na
média
são confundiu a cidade ea união européia
ser respeitada entre o cérebro do trecho
é 5% no consumo global agora já estamos
aqui mostrar veículos transportes
indústria isto é quando minha que
poderia gerar só com estas medidas
seriam cerca de final de ano
o custo de investimento na outra passa
em quinto com 13 bilhões de euros o que
quer dizer que temos aqui um caso de
algum dia alguns conhece que entrou na
plataforma
estamos a falar aqui no caso específico
são clientes têm exatamente a mesma loja
são áreas comerciais são exatamente o
mesmo tipo de solução de venda para os
gráficos a versão os clientes consomem
daquelas linhas a primeira são os que
mais consomem foram reduzidas as faturas
mensais foi feita a análise do conjunto
do edifício e ao fim de dois anos de
implementar
só a monitorização sem fazer mais nada
sem fazer investimentos em ingês com
vários sem fazer investimento em
equipamentos mais eficientes sem alterar
absolutamente nada só a publicação de
que também uma indenização e fornecer
essa informação ao cliente uma forma
muito mais limpa conseguiu atingir uma
produção consumo 15 152 exemplo no caso
dessas lojas todas estamos a falar em 50
milhões e 50 milhões de euros 10
eu vou transcrevê analogia à tecnologia
comprova que nós temos melhor perceção o
do que isso quer dizer
o que a monitorização contínua e e o que
é que isso influencia nos nossos hábitos
e nos nossos comportamentos de consumo
pai
o facto dos carros dos automóveis terem
começado a publicar o consumo médio
consumo instantâneo e por exemplo o
ex-controlador até do do preço do toyota
preso é em que conseguimos aqui ter
inclusivamente o nosso comportamento ao
longo do tempo dos há alguma viagem que
temos aqui uma amostra cerca de 15
minutos isso vou peças assinadas no
consumo do do concílio obstáculos é
exatamente a mesma coisa se passa nos
nossos edifícios
nós não temos a mínima noção do que é
que nosso edifício com o sol
existe outra analogia que se pode fazer
neste bairro
imaginem vocês vão às compras e vocês
não tem preço é absolutamente nenhum
no supermercado chegou ao fim na caixa e
não tem mensal por levar a energia
dentro de casa
- saio soou os consumidores de energia
nós realmente temos um problema com os
nossos foram os dos substitutos dia não
satisfazem as expectativas no
internamento não conseguimos perceber
como é que ao fim de tantos anos
continuamos a ter uma fatura
completamente segue sem perceber como é
que vai a nossa energia
todos querem faturas energéticas mais
reduzidas as pessoas procuram nós como
os de sorvetes dia mais informação sobre
os dias
os clientes valorizam a informação
atualizada sobre medidas de
racionalização energética é é
impressionante a quantidade de gente que
procura e diz quem nós podemos fazer o
que nós podemos fazer é tempo de vocês
vocês vocês é que têm negócio mal
ferramenta mais otan que é a alteração
do comportamento o facto vocês por
exemplo a irem todos os dias pelos
conhecimentos
há 20 anos atrás diz passar assim que
uma uma alteração de comportamento é
exatamente a mesma coisa se vocês querem
mudar os hábitos de consumo em nossa
casa tem que mudar completamente tem
muito exatamente a ausência de
consciência e à ausência de informação
leva a uma falta de comportamento da
sinalização energética e é um símbolo do
levantamento dos edifícios que injecta
muito eficientes
eu posso ter um edifício extremamente
eficiente com o tecnologia bota as
pessoas vão procurar o edifício não
estiverem sensibilizados nem tiverem
informação vida para conseguir em praga
difícil
o edifício vai ser o kaká vai estar
desligado e não vai satisfazer as
necessidades conforto das ferramentas
têm a qualidade de quem as utiliza como
qualquer programador que será falado
aqui as tecnologias de informação
utilização muito mais pressão bolsi
tempo o hospital não espera que o
edifício seja eficiente só sejam celebra
trabalhar não adianta também possuir as
soluções mais eficientes não tivermos
então isso é suficiente
muitas vezes quando nós
é difícil fazer auditoria e tentar
explicar aos técnicos que aumenta se
adotassem outro tipo de estratégias
outro tipo de consciência seria mais
fácil às vezes por ver se este álbum não
é próprio fácil e eles continuam muito
atarefados eu sabem eu sou os donos da
casa e continuam as tarefas delas final
não conseguiu sequer passar a mensagem
que eu digo a vocês é que a
racionalização jéca passa muito tempo a
pressão então a consciência todo o
processo